est en premier lieu pour la vie de mario
paul déjà totalement détruite les russes
auraient fait usage là-bas d'armes
chimiques ce qu'ils démentent
formellement
le royaume-uni est en train d'enquêter
un là dessus
oui effectivement la rumeur est apparue
est apparu cette nuit c'est le régiment
azoff qui la première a annoncé qu'un
drone russe avait happé vaporisé du gaz
sur les militaires et les civils des
noirs aux tranchées qui tentent encore
de défendre le sud et le centre de mario
paul alors cette information n'est pas
confirmée elle n'est pas confirmée par
le gouvernement ukrainien qui lui aussi
mène l'enquêté même si leur dernière
communication dit que les premiers
résultats de l'enquêté préliminaire à 2
montrerait qu'il s'agirait de phosphore
le gouvernement britannique aussi a tout
de suite lancé une enquête pour
confirmer ou infirmer usage d'armes
d'armes chimiques sur sur mario paul
alors toi tout à fait honnête l' usage
d'armes chimiques aujourd'hui dans l'est
de l'ukraine sur mario pouliot srec à
motifs surprenants depuis qu'alexandre
forniquent of a pris la tête dirige
cette armée russe en ukraine il faut
rappeler que c'est lui déjà qui
dirigeait l'armée russe en syrie et il a
prouvé en syrie que le phosphore ou le
gaz toxiques eh bien ils étaient prêts à
l'utiliser mais pour l'instant il n'y a
encore aucune confirmation quant à son
utilisation sur mario paul la seule
chose qui est sûre concernant mario paul
c'est que la ville va tomber aujourd'hui
le siège ne peut plus être prisé par les
forces ukrainienne c'est en tout cas ce
qu'a annoncé le gouvernement hier donc
la ville va tomber ça se compte en
heures où ça se compte en jours le
résultat sera le même les russes vont
faire main basse sur la ville alors
effectivement stratégiquement le gain
sera assez minime pour les russes
puisque la jonction entre la crimée et
les territoires occupés à l'est elle se
fait déjà elle se fait ne serait-ce
qu'en contournant mario paul ça
permettra juste de gagner un petit peu
de temps mais en revanche ça serait un
coup terrible au moral des ukrainiens
alors que s'annonce la grande bataille
de l'est de l'ukraine pour le contrôle
du donbass merci beaucoup et sylvain
roux sur notre envoyé spécial à qui
avait à l'équipe qui vous attend